j'étais prof de philo et à l'entente
imitateurs si vous qui disiez ce ne sont
pas mes narines ce sont mes rêves oui et
non non mais c'est vrai c'est comme les
chaussettes sales de gros coup on a
décidé depuis jamais on parle et voilà
j'ai prêté serment
non mais ça vous plaisait bien qu elle l
aime pas je vous dirai pas se faire
attacher mais en revanche les
chaussettes sales c'est son truc c'est
bien donc prof de philo imitateur
directeur du festival de jazz de nice
comédien dans douze hommes en colère
marigny non moyen de bégon oui
j'essayais de dire c'est que vous avez
comme une image assez brouillé comme ça
oui mais c'est bien ça ça vous plaît ça
oui beaucoup
est ce que vous croyez pas que si vous
n'avez pas la carte comme andy c'est à
cause du fait que vous fait plein de
trucs comme ça différent j'ai une image
un peu brouillée parce que ça veut dire
avoir la carte
non franchement c'est savoir la carte
c'est à dire il ya des mecs qui font
deux films pourris et il y à libération
télérama les inrockuptibles ils disent
que c'est génial
il ya des gens qui font des millions
d'entrées et continue à dire que c'est
pas bien ça s'appelle avoir la carbon je
savais pas j'ai pas la carte puisque
plus vite et ça vous embête du tout ah
bon donc vraiment ça vous embête
franchement bon alors je ne savais même
pas que ça existait sa forme est que
vous étiez prof de philo vous avez été
évincé l'éducation nationale vous allez
garder une grande culture de votre
époque
prof de philo oui j'ai réfléchi
longtemps
donc vous faire une interview culturel
alors pendant le jingle
bien la gaffe belge
sinon pas belge ab le site belge je
crois que tu es suisses vivaient en
suisse
céline dion
quoi sylvain pas belge gérard miller
lara fabian belge bravo mais là enfin
bien les petites halles aux belges
canadiennes s'est conclu mettez des
cultures quand même
van gogh peintre bien bien bien je vous
concentrer là c'est bien prenez ça au
sérieux maux eu des réseaux belges non
italien non non plus français amélie
nothomb les pots belges belge a tu vois
frédéric françois bège bravo mais
sicilien est à l'eau tout compliqué
aussi
bernard rapp belge nom aurait fait
plaisir avec les rebelles
j'ai vu solution combinée greffe c'est
un peu belge bernard kouchner
c'est compliqué c'est dur mais les
problèmes
justin au crâne belge
ouais françoise mallet joris belge belge
roel van lent très envie on est allé non
mais annie cordy une coupelle jean
pierre bachelet pierre bachelet belges
n'ont alors la scission maurane belge
nicolas peyrac pas belge marie gillain à
les belges ouais edouard baer non c'est
le piège ici
bungle fait rire maureen dor
ah oui ben jarry je dois tout de suite
c'est pourquoi
régine régine oui non pas belle elle est
née en belgique à roubaix bab el menzah
belge axelle red
adamou illégaux en partie les italiens
qui sont en belgique ils m'ont rappelé
jean marie messier à jean marie messier
tout à fait pas belge d'accord eddie van
halen abba avec un nom comme ça il est
sûrement pas belle je veux un belge
comme chocolat ou tel ou tel django
reinhardt manouche
ouais mais en belgique ah oui mais ça
c'est anglais damon images
thierry la fronde jean claude roux alors
lui je me rendrai je suis pas bête
même si belle merde à et on termine le
plus difficile isabelle adjani
eh bien figurez vous qu isabelle adjani
n'est pas voilà messieurs m
interview